politique bonsoir et bienvenue dans les
deux politiques votre rendez-vous
politique du dimanche soir sur Radio
sensation en association avec TV 78
épisode 226 ce soir mon invité et le
maire de Brétigny-sur-Orge Nicolas
Méhari
[Musique]
livre de politique
Nicolas Marie bonsoir bonsoir Corentin
lanzeau vous êtes maire de
Brétigny-sur-Orge depuis 2014 une
commune de plus de 27000 habitants dans
le cœur de l'Essonne vous êtes également
depuis 2019 vice-président du
département de l'Essonne en charge de la
transition écologique il y a un an en
octobre 2021 l'ancien Premier ministre
Edouard Philippe a créé un nouveau parti
nommé horizon il y a eu depuis les
élections législatives horizons possède
un groupe aujourd'hui de 30 députés avec
donc ceux qui sont également à parentés
ils forment avec les 170 députés
Renaissance et les 51 députés du MoDem
la majorité relative qui fait parler ces
derniers temps à l'Assemblée nationale
l'article 49-3 a dû être dégainé trois
fois déjà pour faire passer trois textes
budgétaires c'est une méthode
constitutionnelle mais très décrié d'un
point de vue démocratique vous quel est
votre avis à titre personnel sur sur le
49-3 mon avis sur 49-3 c'est que c'est
un moyen insatisfaisant mais qui permet
d'avancer et tout l'enjeu de la
Constitution c'est de permettre au pays
d'avancer même quand il y a dans la
majorité relative bloqué exactement bien
sûr j'aurais préféré avec d'autres nous
aurions préféré que le gouvernement est
une majorité absolue pour pouvoir
soutenir son action néanmoins ce n'est
pas le cas les Français en ont décidé
autrement au moment des élections
législatives et c'est tant mieux que la
Constitution donne les outils pour
pouvoir avancer quand même parce
qu'évidemment on peut pas se permettre 5
années de blocage à la situation
actuelle alors à la suite de ces
différents 49 3 les oppositions ont
déposé plusieurs notions de censure ce
qui sauve entre guillemets le
gouvernement c'est le groupe LR qui ne
l'a pas voté finalement et malgré
tout repose sur eux les donc
l'expression qui revient c'est que les
LR sont la les béquilles de la majorité
est-ce que vous voyez aussi cela comme
je ne vois pas la même manière
c'est-à-dire que en fait la motion de
censure et peut être déposé
mécaniquement en lien avec un 49-3 ce
qui est particulier cette fois-ci c'est
que la motion de censure qui a été
déposée par la nuque a été voté
également par le rassemblement national
et c'est pour cela que le gouvernement
avait une faible une courte avance pour
pouvoir entre guillemets résister si mes
soins de censure mais quelle serait la
majorité alternative est-ce que c'est
une majorité qui irait qui intégrerait
aussi bien la France insoumise que le
rassemblement national je pense que
c'est une vue de l'esprit et c'est
précisément ça qui est inquiétant c'est
que les LFI c'est félicité du résultat
de cette notion de censure en disant que
le gouvernement avait été avait échappé
de justesse mais en se disant mais voilà
en disant nous sommes prêts pour la
relève mais avec qui est-ce qu'ils
veulent gouverner avec le harcèlement
national je pense précisément que ce
serait dangereux pour le pays le
président de la République a cette
semaine tendu la main aux républicain
sur sur France 2 il a appelé à une
alliance avec eux pour faire donc voter
les textes à l'Assemblée nationale
pourquoi est-ce que les républicains
accepteraient auraient intérêt à
accepter cette alliance ils ont été élus
il y a moins de 6 mois sur une ligne
claire d'opposition à Emmanuel Macron et
ce qui était plus Macron compatible ont
déjà franchi le pas ils sont rejoint la
majorité
il pourrait avoir intérêt parce qu'il
veut faire avancer le pays et encore une
fois nous sommes dans une période de
transition extrêmement forte il y a des
sujets majeurs il y a des crises
fondamentales la crise géopolitique la
crise sanitaire la crise de l'énergie et
on a besoin que le pays puisse avancer
et alors je crois que le point important
c'est prendre acte du fait que le
gouvernement n'a pas une majorité
absolue il faut donc discuter faire des
compromis entendre les points de vue qui
peuvent être apportés par d'autres
forces politiques et au final arriver un
accord dans d'autres pays ça se fait
très naturellement en Allemagne par
exemple il y a une culture de la
discussion démocratique qui est bien
plus forte je pense que les républicains
sonoreraient à pouvoir dire ok on est
prêt à discuter de certains textes voici
les points sur lesquels nous voulons
désavancer nous voulons notre
sensibilité sois prise en compte je
pense que tous celles et ceux qui ont
envie de faire avancer le pays devraient
en ce moment travailler ensemble chacun
avec ses convictions mais travailler
ensemble le parti Horizon a été fondé le
9 octobre 20 vous étiez l'un des
premiers à le rejoindre dès ça sa
fondation avant vous étiez membre
uniquement de l'UDI l'Union des
démocrates indépendants qu'est-ce qui
vous a poussé à rejoindre le parti
d'Édouard Philippe un positionnement
stratégique clair le Édouard Philippe
représente avec d'autres sensibilité de
centre droit et sensibilité libérale
sociale européenne pour engager pour
être transition écologique et il y a
dans le parti horizon que nous avons
souhaité constituer autour d'Edouard
Philippe il y a un choix qui est clair
qui est de travailler de contribuer à la
majorité présidentielle d'Emmanuel
Macron l'UDI a fait des choix différents
pour les élections législatives
notamment il y avait un accord avec les
républicains donc on s'inscrivant
effectivement dans l'opposition Emmanuel
Macron j'avais eu l'occasion de le dire
pendant un certain nombre d'années à
l'UDI c'est que pour sur bien des sujets
Emmanuel Macron mettait en œuvre le
projet politique que l'udaïs porté avec
bien sûr des différences de méthodes
enfin nous ne sommes pas forcément
d'accord surtout et justement ce
qu'Horizon apporte au sein de la
majorité président essentiel c'est de
faire valoir une sensibilité
particulière une attention au territoire
un rapport à l'ensemble du pays un
rapport charnel avec le pays qui est
très présent dans la réflexion horizon
et qui peut-être est un peu moins forte
dans des parties d'un parti comme
Renaissance au départ vous l'avez dit
donc pour le moment horizon se place en
soutien de du parti donc de renaissance
mais jusqu'à quand Édouard Philippe a
montré plusieurs fois déjà quelques
désaccords avec Emmanuel Macron comme
aussi le patron du MoDem François Bayrou
qui compose aussi la maison commune
comme vous l'appelez les députés modem
et horizons n'ont pas hésité à proposer
des amendements contre l'avis du
gouvernement notamment sur les lois de
donc du PLF 2023 sur le projet de loi de
finance est-ce qu'il y a une volonté
aussi de se différencier un petit peu de
de renaissance de peser de bousculer un
peu le parti d'Emmanuel Macron je crois
qu'il y a une volonté à la fois de
porter des idées qui nous paraissent
importantes et une volonté aussi d'être
entendue au sein de la majorité être un
partenaire loyal au sein de la majorité
gouvernementale ça ne veut pas forcément
dire être le petit doigt sur la couteau
du pantalon tout le temps et les
amendements que vous évoquez sont sur
des sujets importants et un premier
amendement qui est au cœur de l'été
était cela question du soutien au
département dans la mise en œuvre du RSA
en disant bah le département le
gouvernement augmenté la charge des
départements Horizon a considérer qu'il
était légitime de apporter un soutien
financier à cru au département
permettez-moi de vous dire qu'en tant
que vice-président du conseil
départemental et l'Essonne je pense
qu'ils avaient absolument raison que les
députés horizons ont porté un discours
qui est qui est juste de bon sens
évidemment l'état travaille avec les
collectivités territoriales mais il faut
prendre en compte ses préoccupes des
territoires et c'est aussi le cas de
l'amendement de proposition de cette
semaine sur portée par le porte-parole
Thomas Meunier sur la question de de
pouvoir inciter avec des de manière
assez forte des les jeunes médecins à
s'installer dans des zones qui sont
carencées dans des armes médicaux on a
besoin de problématique on a besoin
essentielles dans les territoires on le
sait et je crois ou justement que
c'était des amendements qui défin une
ligne l'attention au territoire parmi
les personnalités qui ont rejoint
horizon il y a Christian Estrosi mère de
Nice Nathalie Loiseau l'ancienne tête de
liste pour les européennes de 2019 et
députés européennes Hubert Falco le
maire de Toulon Arnaud Péricard maire de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye dans les Yvelines
aussi le député Laurent Marc Angeli
ancien maire d'Ajaccio mais aussi
Christophe BECHU ancien maire d'Angers
désormais ministre de la transition
écologique un poste éminemment important
au vu des enjeux actuels il est aussi
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
c'est pas un hasard il appelait des pour
une nouvelle méthode de travail avec les
collectivités fondées donc sur la
confiance et une plus grande autonomie
vous êtes justement vice-président du
conseil départemental de l'Essonne en
charge de la transition écologique
est-ce que l'on sera plus efficace il
est collectivités locales s'empare de
des projets environnementaux et en plus
de moyens surtout sur sur les projets
alors absolument d'abord la transition
écologique ne pourra se faire qu'en lien
avec les territoires déjà parce que
parmi il y a bien des sujets ce sont les
collectivités territoriales communes
ration départements région qui sont en
charge opérationnellement de les mettre
en oeuvre il y a bien des bâtiments
publics bienvements qui sont gérés aussi
par ces collectivités et donc évidemment
évidemment qu'il faut le faire et les
collectivités territoriales je voudrais
avant de préciser ce point-là revenir un
instant sur ce que la liste des
personnalités que vous avez évoquées qui
ont rejoint horizon il y a énormément de
mer de maire de de grandes villes de mer
ou de vie de toutes tailles qui sont
impliquées au sein de l'horizon et c'est
un élément de notre ADN pourquoi parce
que nous considérons que nous avons par
rapport à Renaissance qui ont moins de
et au moment où en fait il y a eu un la
mise en place d'une encumule des mandats
on s'est rendu compte qu'une partie de
leur présentation nationale était plus
éloignée des territoires qu'auparavant
un des convictions d'horizons c'est que
les maires les élus locaux ont des
choses à dire qui concernent les débat
national et c'est aussi pour cela qu'il
y a cette attention au territoire aux
collectivités territorial alors
précisément Christophe BECHU l'exprime
le dit que justement la transition
écologique devra se faire avec les
collectivités territoriales et il y a
d'ailleurs des mesures qui sont déjà en
train d'être mises en œuvre le fameux
fond vert qui est dans le montant était
significativement augmenté de la voilà à
200000000 pour une 2023 qui est là pour
justement faciliter les investissements
rendus nécessaires dans les territoires
justement Nelson est-ce que vous avez
des idées de projets qui pourraient
bénéficier de ce fond vert il y a
énormément de sujets sur lesquels on est
seul il y a des choses à faire que ce
soit cela rénovation la génétique des
bâtiments sur que ce soit sur les
projets aussi pour pouvoir
des imperméabiliser des cours d'école de
collège au niveau départemental il y a
aussi dans les sujets essentiels qui
nécessitent des investissements très
importants toute une réflexion à mener
sur la production d'énergie renouvelable
ça fait partie aussi des points sur
lesquels le Conseil départemental
s'engage très fortement pour que on
essaie nous prenions notre part un des
dossiers brûlant du moment ce sont les
zones à faibles émissions Les ZF comme
on les appelle à partir de 2025 les
voitures critères 3 ne pourront plus
rouler donc dans une zone qui comprend
79 villes autour de Paris les habitants
de Brétigny donc comme beaucoup d'autres
ne pourront donc plus se rendre dans
cette zone en voiture s'ils n'ont pas
une voiture trop polluante c'est déjà le
cas donc pour les critères 4 et plus
pour certains c'est des feux sont des
zones à forte exclusion écouter Mathilde
Android député européenne du
rassemblement national elle s'oppose
fermement à ses eaux j'estime qu'il faut
défendre vraiment notre environnement ça
clairement la biodiversité qui va avec
mais ça ne passera pas par l'exclusion
d'une partie de la population je trouve
ça
igname en fait à partir du moment où
vous dites à certains
ben écoutez l'écologie c'est un sport de
riche donc sortez ça l'autre pauvre j'ai
beaucoup de mal avec ça en fait parce
que la réalité c'est ça ils ont renié la
réalité c'est ça c'est des gens qui
notamment dans les zones périphériques
rurales cherche des médecins cherche des
services publics n'en n'ont plus donc
s'auto obligé d'aller en métropole et
comment font-ils souvent avec des
véhicules qui n'ont pas le critère
établi par je ne sais quel lobby
peut-être en plus automobile donc faut
vraiment s'interroger aussi là dessus je
trouve ça anormal moi les politiques qui
consistent à éclure à exclure une partie
de la ma population mes frères mais
voilà mais des Français pour moi est une
politique unique est-ce que c'est de
l'écologie punitive c'est
c'est un point sur lesquels auquel il
faut être très attentif il ne faut
évidemment pas que la mise en oeuvre
d'une ZFE se traduisent par l'exclusion
une partie de la population je suis élu
d'un département de grandes couronnes
nous savons que sur bien des sujets la
question du rapport au centre de la
période de la métropole parisienne est
un enjeu extrêmement important rappelons
que les investissements publics en
matière de transport en commun pour la
grande couronne ont été
significativement plus faibles que ceux
pour Paris la petite couronne alors que
justement il y a des besoins extrêmement
une fois qu'on a dit ça je pense qu'il
est important en matière de transition
écologique de se donner un cap dans la
durée et de mettre en oeuvre les mesures
d'accompagnement qui sont nécessaires je
avec François Durovray nous portons
l'idée que il faut
au même moment le président du
Département de conseil départemental
absolument vous avez raison de le
rappeler
il faut en même temps travailler sur des
lignes de bus express parce que il faut
pouvoir renforcer les mobilités qui vont
permettre de rejoindre efficacement le
centre de la région parisienne métropole
parisienne sur lesquels on travaille
dans lesquels beaucoup de nous de nos
concitoyens travaillent il faut qu'il y
ait un cap résolu pour la transition
écologique les aides de mission
en font sans doute partie mais c'est
qu'un enjeu un projet qui doit concerner
l'ensemble du territoire donc avant les
solutions alternatives accompagner les
français pour le changement la
transition le changement de véhicule
parce qu'il ne faut pas que des gens se
retrouvent exclus c'est à cette
condition là c'est à cette condition là
que les et des feux pour autre mise en
oeuvre personnellement je pense sera
surjet sur lequel il ne faut pas se
précipiter même si dans la durée il faut
avancer sur la réduction des émissions
mais pour répondre aux inquiétudes
Christophe Béchu a évoqué pour les
particuliers résidents ou travaillant
dans une ZFE la possibilité de souscrire
un prêt à taux zéro à hauteur de 30000
euros pour remplacer donc
ces vieilles voitures et donc pour
l'achat d'un véhicule neuf ou une
location longue durée plus donc plus
écologique c'est une solution qui sera
suffisante selon vous pour inciter les
les gens à donc à changer leur voiture
ça aidera ça aidera c'est c'est une
mesure qui va dans la bonne direction je
pense que sur un sujet comme celui-là
qui est un changement majeur on ne prend
pas encore toute la mesure de l'impact
que ça va avoir sur nos vies elle le
c'est
arrêtons-nous dans l'histoire là-dessus
si vous voulez bien parce que c'est
vraiment je crois si on emblématique des
questions de transition il faut à la
fois définir un CAP de long terme et
c'est bien d'avoir un câble de long
terme on peut faire le parallèle avec un
autre sujet qui est le zéro
artificialisation net il faut
penser que nous allons réduire la
consommation d'espace pour notre pour
notre développement parce que de long
terme mais il faut prendre aussi la
mesure du fait que cette transition elle
va toucher d'abord les foyers les plus
modestes les gens qui vont être les plus
éloignés du centre de la métropole et
toutes les efforts très importants en
matière d'accompagnement sont absolument
nécessaires pour que cette transition
soit partagée par tous et soit réussie
mais pour éviter de prendre la voiture
il y a aussi donc les transports en
commun depuis le début de l'année la
situation est très compliquée sur donc
l'ensemble des lignes vous en savez
quelque chose Brétigny et desservi par
le RER C à travers une tribune
collective 15 présidents de région
militent pour un New Deal ferroviaire il
souhaite un grand plan de 100 milliards
sur les 10 prochaines années 10
milliards par an financé par les
collectivités l'état l'Europe et la SNCF
annoncé un plan de 180 milliards
l'Allemagne 90 milliards un plan pour
rénover développer le ferroviaire vous
vous dites oui bien sûr bien sûr
évidemment les présidents de région ont
raison de la tribune et la comparaison
vous rappelez justement nos voisins
européens montre bien que les différents
grands pays européens ont pris en mesure
de l'enjeu c'est absolument nécessaire
d'abord pour une raison simplement
climatique le on estime que le train
émet 10 à 30 fois moins de CO2 de
trois fois mon impact sur le dérèglement
climatique que la voiture et donc
évidemment il faut qu'on trouve les
modalités pour que le train puisse être
véritable solution qui fonctionne pour
cela ça nécessite des investissements
très importants on sait qu'on a on a
manqué d'investissement dans les
infrastructures pendant pendant des
années on le voit effectivement sur le
RER C où il nous faut il faut 10 ans 15
ans pour rattraper le retard
d'investissement il faut aussi une
stratégie pour l'ensemble de la filière
parce que justement c'est aussi la
fracture mais c'est aussi les
innovations qui vont permettre une
interconnexion de manière plus efficace
des changements de pratique tout cela
c'est nécessaire les présidents de
région absolument raison il faut
investir massivement dans le train et
nous allons passer maintenant la
deuxième partie de l'émission
politique
toujours avec Nicolas Mehari maire
horizon de Brétigny-sur-Orge on parlait
des trains à l'instant brésigné est une
ville une ville fortement liée au
ferroviaire ce mercredi le verdict du
procès de la catastrophe de
Brétigny-sur-Orge et tombé il aura fallu
neuf ans pour que la justice soit rendue
le 12 juillet 2013 le train Intercité
Paris Limoges a déraillé à cause d'un
décrochage d'une éclisse une pièce
métallique qui relie les rails entre
l'accident a fait 7 morts et une
centaine de blessés pour la SNCF la
faute était due à un défaut indécelable
de l'acier c'est la position qu'elle a
défendu lors du procès finalement elle
est reconnue donc coupable d'homicide et
de blessures à volontaire a été condamné
à une amende de 300000 euros et un total
de 3,5 millions de dommages et intérêts
sera versé aux victimes vous n'étiez pas
encore mère à quand c'est arrivé en 2013
vous avez ensuite suivi le
questionnement et la reconstruction des
victimes de ce drame que ressentez-vous
après cette décision
nous avons maintenant une vérité
judiciaire qui était établie et c'est un
point extrêmement important pour pour la
suite
déjà pour les familles des victimes
pour pouvoir continuer de se
reconstruire et au fil des années on vu
comment on a ils ont tout exprimé la
volonté de la foi de savoir
parce que c'était nécessaire pour
pouvoir passer à la suite et aussi
savoir ça peut te permettre d'en tirer
les enseignements et c'est aussi cela
permet cette vérité judiciaire ce n'est
pas la même chose quand les
interlocuteurs SNCF dit non non on
pouvait pas savoir vous ne pouvez pas on
ne pouvait pas identifier les causes et
quand il est établi que il y avait un
défaut maintenant dans les procédures
dans les moyens qui étaient mis en
oeuvre je pense que le
verdict de ce type est toujours
imparfait en tout cas tout le monde
c'est une vérité judiciaire je salue le
fait qu'il n'est pas forcément fait
peser l'ensemble de la responsabilité
sur le chef d'équipe locale c'est plutôt
sur les procédures qui étaient mises en
œuvre
en tant que mère de Brétigny je veux
dire que c'était cet accident cette
catastrophe ferroviaire a été évidemment
un traumatisme pour la ville c'était le
brétienne cheminots et on a beaucoup de
gens ont été très touchés on a on
attendait ce verdict on attendait le
fait qu'on puisse se dire voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour la suite et on
espère que cela servira à pouvoir
prendre les bonnes décisions matières
d'investissement justement sur
l'infrastructure sur l'entretien des
infrastructures sur les procédures parce
que la première chose que nous demandons
que les familles des victimes demandent
c'est qu'une telle drame ne se
reproduise pas je voudrais juste ajouter
vous permettez deux choses sur ce point
là la première il faut saluer tout le
travail qui était mené pendant le procès
qui est pas mis l'expression de de
l'ensemble des victimes de beaucoup
d'experts c'était très important et puis
se dire en même temps que 9 ans neuf ans
après l'effet pour aboutir un verdict
dans d'autres pays on a réussi enfin
beaucoup plus vite par exemple pour le
pont morandiagène le délai était
beaucoup plus bref on peut regretter
qu'on mette autant de temps même si nous
avons maintenant une vérité judiciaire
ça la force la possibilité d'avancer un
nouveau logo pour l'Essonne le président
du Département François Durovray a
dévoilé ce mois-ci un nouveau logo pour
donc forger une identité forte telle est
la nouvelle ambition du département vous
voulez que l'Essonne est un totem les
Yvelines ont Versailles la scène et
Marne ont Disneyland une réflexion va
être menée quelle est votre avis sur sur
la question alors d'abord nous dire que
à nouveau logo effectivement pour
pouvoir contribuer au rayonnement de
notre département nous avons été
attentifs à faire cela d'une manière
sauf que cela représente de coûts
supplémentaire c'est un logo qui a été
travaillé en interne et surtout pour
tous les les mises à jour de documents
de de
bannière enfin nous avons attendu des
renouvellements pour éviter que cela
crée un surcoût c'est important parce
que s'agit pas de faire de la com pour
de la com ce logo il comptait il est là
pour pouvoir contribuer au rayonnement
de l'Essonne on se rend compte que notre
département est souvent méconnu cela a
des conséquences assez concrètes sur la
capacité des entreprises il a recruté la
capacité à valoriser les les les les les
découvertes les recherches les travaux
le patrimoine naturel de l'Essonne et
donc c'est un élément d'identité fort je
pense que nous sommes tous les les
avocats les ambassadeurs du pays de
notre département alors totem
la question est difficile et c'est bien
pour cela d'ailleurs que nous avons
voulu à poser la poser aux etiens je
crois que la particularité de
département c'est qu'il y a énormément
de choses qui représentent
les scènes que ce soit le cresson de
Méréville que ce soit la recherche à
sacrée que ce soit des projets
ambitieux comme ce qu'on pourrait avoir
dans le sur le sur l'ancien centre
d'essai en vol la culture à chamaran
culture nous avons des joyaux comme le
domaine de Méréville nous avons il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont qui sont
formidables en Essonne
nous avons l'embarras du choix nous
avons un département particulièrement
riche de tous patrimoine se diversité
donc on l'achète avec impatience de
savoir ce que les aides vont suggéré je
pense aussi à la base 217 justement qui
se situe entre Brétigny et le
Plessis-Pâté elle a accueilli récemment
la Fête de l'Humanité il y a aussi un
projet de création de studio de cinéma
qui est en cours et il y a aussi la mise
en place d'un pôle d'excellence dédié au
drone comment est-ce que vous voyez
l'avenir de ce lieu un peu particulier
dans en Essonne
c'est aussi le projet sur le cinéma qui
est en cours de préparation de
l'ambition un cap un développement
équilibré c'est ce que nous souhaitons
pour la reconversion des terrains de son
des serveurs mais pour mener à bien tous
ces projets il faudra des
investissements aujourd'hui la crise
énergétique d'impact fortement le budget
des communes l'Association des maires de
France la miss a publié un cri d'alarme
dans une lettre une tribune que vous
avez signé vous aussi écoutez votre
collègue au sein du conseil
départemental Dominique Bougros elle est
maire de Lardy je ne peux que relayer ce
secret d'alerte
d'alerte d'alarme de de presque
désespoir parce que un certain nombre de
communes ne vont pas pouvoir boucler
leur budget 2023 avec la meilleure
volonté du monde et ça va être
dramatique si vous voulez on nous a
informé on a reçu des lettres de des
fournisseurs le gaz c'est multiplié par
5 ou 7 fois et l'électricité aux
environs de deux et demi pour une
commune comme Lardy on de 350 000 euros
à un million 3 voilà un million de Delta
moi je sais pas faire plus d'autres
choses mais qui sont justifiées comme le
point d'indice à l'évaluation du point
d'indice pour les agents etc voilà c'est
des sommes considérables et aujourd'hui
moi je ne sais pas faire alors je ne
sais pas faire ça implique deux choses
essentielles donc il va falloir
peut-être nier sur des services publics
aujourd'hui les gens sont telle
difficulté que renier sur des services
publics voilà c'est le le signe est
absolument catastrophique et peu de gens
parlent et moi je pense que c'est
absolument dramatique il faut quand même
savoir que dans le bâtiment le premier
dormeur d'ordre ce sont les
collectivités donc si demain moi je ne
peux pas dégager d'autofinancement je ne
peux plus investir donc je ne peux plus
solliciter les entreprises
quel impact sur le budget de la commune
de Brétigny c'est le moment la fin de
l'année où on vote les budgets pour la
suite je souscris totalement aux propos
Dominique Bougro
Brétigny sur on va multiplier la facture
de gaz à consommer ces régals quasiment
par 6 c'était 300.000 euros par an pour
chauffer les bâtiments municipaux là à
consommation égale on serait
1,7,7 millions d'euros c'est à dire que
c'est évidemment très important pour une
commune comme la mienne avec alors on
arrive à faire face mais c'est la réduit
très fortement la capacité de
financement des investissements et donc
cela va nécessiter de réflonner le plan
d'investissement que nous pouvions avoir
alors au résultat on fait on a lancé un
plan de sobriété pour pouvoir chercher à
réduire cette consommation d'énergie
parce que évidemment un prix pareil
c'est intenable pour pour les communes
pour l'ensemble la collectivités nous
étions
mobiliser avec la MIF ça concerne
également le Conseil départemental qui a
lancé son plan de sobriété c'est
si on essaie de voir ça de manière un
tout petit peu optimiste un instant
c'est que cela va peut-être nous aider à
aller plus vite sur les investissements
nécessaires pour la réduction des
consommations et donc par la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique qui est
le point positif on va rester sur cette
note positif pour conclure merci
beaucoup Nicolas Merry merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes Le Maire horizon de
Brétigny-sur-Orge et vice-président du
conseil départemental de l'Essonne
chargé de la transition écologique nous
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine on
invité sera alors le maire de
Vélizy-Villacoublay Pascal thevenouf
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]